this suggestion comes from anna who  watches our show all the way from  monterrey mexico  do a whole et themed episode huh  i'm down with that  let's see what do we need for an e.t  themed episode phones plants i mean by  the way i love hearts and flowers and i  don't have to ask myself twice it  clearly came from e.t he had the big red  beating heart which said he was alive  well and happy and then those flowers  were emblematic of his health and  wellness too hearts and flowers  changed my life so we'll have hearts and  flowers maybe e.t maybe we'll ring up  steven spielberg um see if some other  cast members would show up  but again keep the suggestions coming  anna et also has its 40th anniversary in  2022.  i see some symmetry there